[Music]
and fake it till you make it news
submitted by bar top willis villain
watch propolis robotropolis yes they
spelled it bar top of it are topless
they [ __ ] it up yeah we got to figure
out where bar propolis is well where's
shamalia well is it in relevant relation
yeah relation to John Mallia where is so
is it in John Mallia or is it a town
outside or within your King knows within
you get is it within the realm it's
south of Steve City that's what it is
yeah Steve City inside oh it's tight
I'll tell you about it someday it's
great Steve sees great truly coming up
to next to the David River use get a
river I don't want to control anything I
just want to give water to everybody it
does has fish I do picture a date Dave
it's like a lazy river yeah everyone's
in tubes just hanging out and then you
get like a soda and you get like chips
and you just I think it's like the LA
River people like this is a river moved
to the city I was like there's like you
see the LA River I was like where I see
concrete yeah you mean that big gutter
yeah meaning you look at houses lately
and those guys like oh it's grace right
by the LA River and I'm like I know you
mean homeless highway yeah right exactly
she just slap them at that point don't
you [ __ ] talk to be like a child I
would say you know what you should have
said it's like you know they film
terminan or two in their [ __ ] that drive
drive was film in there fast and furious
that's better than GTA a writer tricked
Tripadvisor into making his shed a
number one ranked restaurant in London
you're gonna love it
he's a troll he's a master I love this
guy already but a [ __ ] good yeah so
this guy he's a freelance writer he
writes for Vice we talked about him
before his name is Bob Butler he's 26
years old we talked about him before he
was the guy that let his Instagram
followers dictate his life for a day oh
that was very sick yeah so he claims
that before he got steady writing jobs
that he used to make side money by
writing fake reviews for restaurant
owners on TripAdvisor
for like 10 so like restaurant owners
will pay reviewers - yes pump up their
stuff
so huge charge 10 pounds per post and
like he wouldn't even eat at these
places he was just be writing reviews he
says this about TripAdvisor quote this
convinced me that TripAdvisor was a
false reality that the meals never took
place that the reviews were all written
by other people like me however they're
not of course they're almost all
completely genuine and there was one
other factor that seemed impossible to
fake the restaurants themselves so I
moved on and then one day sitting in the
shed I live in I had a revelation within
the current climate of misinformation
and society's willingness to believe
absolute [ __ ] maybe a fake
restaurant is possible maybe it's
exactly the kind of place that could be
a hit in that moment it became my
mission with the help of fake reviews
mystique and nonsense I was gonna do it
turn my shed into London's top rated
restaurant on TripAdvisor
which he did so that's great so he
created a fake restaurant and got all of
his home used to like write fake reviews
yeah number one why cuz other people
started writing reviews yeah because the
only people it's just I guess for some
reason they just felt like I may never
use TripAdvisor but think about the top
rated restaurant though and like how
many comments that would have like 400
on TripAdvisor
like you could catch up for that pretty
cool 18,000 restaurants he got to number
one that's amazing and none of the
reviews they just made up like the 8th
there he had like he got his friends to
like write fake reviews and they would
upload fake photos and like he just
created an entire but there were other
people that just started writing stuff
or yeah cause he was saying that there
were people writing like he had never
even met or like they didn't even know
yeah yeah it's no different than the
yellow pages right like what was the
Yellow Page is it like you had to pay to
get in the yellow pages and if you paid
a certain amount of money you got a
better spot it's the same [ __ ] but
everyone acts like it's so much better
mmm like it's it's still the same thing
it always the same as it ever was it's
just people paying for reviews to get
you to the top to get to the top I
missed the yellow pages cuz we used to
prank call like so many people on the
Vice of pages of the yellow pages and
then like I would sit there and before
Yelp before all this stuff I would like
look page to page at all the different
businesses and then I found this thing
called the military surplus and I didn't
know what that was
but I just saw like
guns and like army [ __ ] and I begged my
dad to take me there and I was like why
don't fought to goodbye army stuff it
was the best day of my life I had to go
through the white pages and look for my
crushes I can call them but I can never
find them you're a stalker dude I was i
I realized later on that it's probably
be listening to the parents name and so
my second grade crush isn't gonna be
listed in the white pages but I would go
through all of them that's why I would
just follow my second grade crush
wherever you want just way easier way to
manage yeah so this dude
he created fake photos of five-star
meals with household items like bleach
shaving foam paint and one phone photo
he even used like his foot massager
so this is the shed at Dulwich which is
the name of the shed his restaurant so
this is his backyard
brick has menus they create an entire
website he created a logo everything
with help of friends and for his menu he
they would serve up moods instead of
like actual dishes the break that we
made it would be like lust and less
would be like rabbit kidneys on toast
seasoned with saffron and oyster bits
served with a side of pomegranate
souffle Oh empathetic contemplation love
comfort that sounds like a [ __ ]
restaurant in LA Cafe Gratitude where
you have to walk in there and tell them
what you're grateful for for you to get
served food how about this I'll give you
money give me my [ __ ] food I'm
grateful good that I only had to pay
$100 for parking [ __ ] let me sit down
yeah like they said that they're like so
what are you grateful for today I'm like
get the [ __ ] out of my face and give you
my food how about that [ __ ] and like
sherrod asked you leave your beer it's
the vegan spot it's a vegan spot where
by the way the food is not that good and
la opinión miss opinion Jorah lust or
did you order jealousy I ordered hater
which is a big snake it's a it's a very
interesting experience I understand what
they're trying to do I just don't like
yeah Ubbe he said that his restaurant is
an appointment-only restaurant located
in South London
and that it has been operating privately
for years and so in 2017 they decided to
open the doors and as of November that
year it was Trip Advisor's number one
rated restaurant in London so he bought
a burner phone so you could register the
phone number for the restaurant and he
got a ton of calls people were crazy
trying to book reservations trying to
get into this well if it's not number
one spot in like London yeah you know
what he did a good job making it look
like fine dining or something but the
actual ingredients are in Bleach for
toilet it's a bleach tab weight shaving
foam black pepper and I don't know what
that other thing in this case [ __ ]
cool and then this one it actually looks
kind of good it doesn't look like a what
is that a not a cookie but like a
brownie with ice cream that's what he's
trying to make it look like but it's
actually like shaving foam and bleach
yeah more bleach spray paint the bleach
and then like this one looks like an egg
so this is for his website he doesn't
bring this out to guests who come no no
one comes so okay so nobody comes it's a
Thai restaurant no it's an appointment
we never gave the address no never why
see we got two bit we got booked up for
the next 40 years yeah yeah this photo
was really his foot his foot is either
blown out or he's dead well he's a
freelance writer well I thought time he
was yeah well he's Phileas so then if
it's my dad that means he doesn't have a
job so for a few months there were a lot
of people trying to get reservations to
this place there's just all this hype
created around this fake restaurant so
then finally he decided to actually open
the restaurant for one night only and so
he tried to recreate the experience that
all these fake reviews were saying and
so he said that this quote we serve
people ready meals dressed up as fancy
meals we used edible flowers we had a
deejay for
beyond we had chickens there that people
could theoretically select for their
meal kind of like how some restaurants
have lobsters in the tank it was really
just a collection of chairs in a garden
shed but all of them left saying how
nice it was and so he didn't charge
anyone for a meal because he said that
he was documenting it for a TV show and
so he had people oh they're gonna be
looking like fools
well he blurred out their faces okay so
I'm gonna show you guys some photos of
that night when he finally up so he
hired like some friends like actors to
pretend that they were also patrons of
that cuz people are just gonna be a part
of that they're just gonna bandwagon a
yes when they went to McDonald's and he
went to that Food Fair and they chopped
up all the chicken nuggets and they were
serving it to all these life highbrow
connoisseurs and they're like oh it's
it's amazing the texture is like box
wine trying to pass it as bad that's
[ __ ] Yelp culture though a hundred
percent they come in and they act like
they know everything and never you know
like like even like when I hear people
talk about wine it's like [ __ ] you
don't know [ __ ] it's like a cigarette
[ __ ] you know what though I thought the
same [ __ ] and then I watched this
documentary called Somme where these
cats are blindfolding themselves like
trying different well I'm talking about
them it's just like the Builder [ __ ] but
you don't select Oh 1923 winter don't
know don't know the season the region
the area and they could guess it very
pretty [ __ ] well it's crazy it's it's
funny to like Holly this private it's so
it's like freshly cut tires grass in the
wind we want a few some cherry taste
it's like what what it's a few city to
me and you can I don't know what that
[ __ ] war means to any people try to
kill themselves they don't [ __ ] pass
that [ __ ] either
Yeah right exactly and then they leave
their wives and their kids at home and
they let go try to be a Somme because if
you get the gig it's like a hundred G's
a year or something yeah and there's
only a few that are like elite like that
in the world cuz you don't even have the
palette for it yes in fact I don't even
palette for Monster energy drinks yeah
[Music]
sugar free yeah the white cat is my
favorite yeah help me to Camden 2011 yes
so he set up a team
and some chairs and like actors on the
roof of his house it could look like
extra dope fancy and so he had people
Needham near his house because they're
gonna go he didn't give them the exact
address so he would meet them all and
then blindfold Emma cold [ __ ] oh well
fun yeah walk him over to his house and
so this is like the meal so it was just
ready like a microwave meals
if Casey blindfolded you and try to take
you to a restaurant and you knew case he
was being blindfolded as well you would
not you be no go right she would
actually do it cuz she would go I do
Nikki would be like [ __ ] get me out
of here well she's been kidnapped like
seven times I'm like dang like I'm a
full story I'm gonna make fun of she has
been I don't look there but yeah look we
know the end yeah so then here's the
d-day look at that piece of [ __ ] that's
so funny people that they don't know
that they're being the subject of this
whole thing
and they were saying like he was just
mentioning in his article too like there
was one couple that you could tell if
they were just disappointed this other
couple were like well can we book in
advance I booked my wedding here yeah
like they were just like we loved it it
was nice can we book them information do
you think it did the disappointed
couples like we're just in some guys
backyard had that conversation probably
yeah then so yeah here is on TripAdvisor
reached number one out of eighteen
thousand ninety two restaurants in
London guys it's genius now you're
saying that there were celebrities
calling like quickly just everyone was
trying to get reservation you grant
warning in you know who's the celebrity
in London or anything
my Jude Law yeah there you go there you
go
that's it Simon Cowell yes the
TripAdvisor ended up deleting the page
and so for this piece here he asked
TripAdvisor and so TripAdvisor had a
statement for this they said generally
the only people who create fake
restaurant listings are journalists and
misguided attempts to test us as there
is no incentive for anyone in the real
world to create a fake restaurant it is
not a problem we experienced with their
regular community therefore this test is
not a
real-world example that we've got to
number one yeah it's a it's a real it's
a great example cuz we ask them like how
could he get how could be like sidestep
all of them because there's no checks
and balances there's yeah hey exactly
that's we trying to prove Yelp any of
these things it's not regulated yeah
[Music]